[موسيقى]
جاء الى اللقائهم في هذه الحديقه قربه
جامعتهم
[موسيقى]
ان ينتزع المنصب من حكم تكساس الجمهوري
وله خطاب لا يحيد عنه لاقناع الشباب
[موسيقى]
لكن الغاء الحق في الاجهاض من المحكمه
العليا الفيدراليه صدم الكثيرين
واشعر بالخوف من العالم الذي نعيش فيه
اليوم
ستؤذي الكثيرين
على الشبكات الاجتماعيه وسيله جيده اخرين
ورائي
للحمله هذه اول مره اتطوع للمرور على
البيوت ويساعدني ذلك اشعر ان الناس
المعتدلون وقد يميلون لهذا الجانب او ذاك
احيانا مجرد ان شخصا تكلف على المجيء اليك
قد يقلب الموازين هذا المرشح ديمقراطي في
ذيل الاستطلاعات لذلك فتركيز حملته على حق
الاجهاض ليس اعتباديا
خاصه في الشباب
يرفعون لافته ضد الاجهاض
من بينهم هذه الناشطه
كان وسجل المحتدم قبيل الانتخابات
الا اذا كان خطرا على حياه الحامل وهذا لا
يكفي براي الناشطين
اجهاض ومعركتنا في كل ولايه اي اقتراح
قوانين محليه حول الحياه منذ التكوين وحضر
الاجهاض بالادويه او عند بدايه نبض القلب
هذا ما يريده الطلاب لاجل الحياه في كل
ولايه وهو وطنيا
[موسيقى]
لا تفتح ثوابت ساعات في الاسبوع
رغم ما يبدو انه نصر عظيم يواصل حماه حق
الحياه معركتهم لتغيير العقليات
في هذه الكنيسه شمال اوستن بعد القداس دعي
المؤمنون واغلبهم من الاثنين اللاتينيه
الى مشاهده فحص شعاعي للجنين
[موسيقى]
مباشر من خلف شاشه
والاطفال في الصف الاول
نيكل
جمعيه ضد الاجهاض لتؤيد كلام الطبيبه
بمنشورات ومجسمات الجنه
الحيه ستكون في خطر اذا تخرب بيت اورورا
يستخدم
[موسيقى]
ثم ياتي دور المتطوعين
سالنا المسجلين الجدد عن همومهم
وابي من الجيل القديم يرون ان الاجهاض
مناف للانجيل
لقله التسجيل افردها على القوائم
الانتخابي
اذا بدانا
نجاح او افشاله
ذوات الاصول اللاتينيه من بين الاكثر
تضررا من حضر الاجهاض
[موسيقى]